bonsoir bienvenue pour le journal sur tv
fil 78 chaque soir de la semaine
l'essentiel de l'actualité locale et
dans les titres aujourd'hui le centre
nautique de mort pas fermée pour raisons
de sécurité une fermeture mais au moins
provisoire dans l'attenté d'une nouvelle
expertise et qui permettra de chiffrer
le montant des travaux nécessaires
engagé changer le regard sur le handicap
une semaine dédiée vient de débuter il
encourt nous en parlerons avec benoît
noble conseiller municipal en charge de
cette question pour la ville
et puis une nouvelle animation en son et
lumière pour le château de breteuil
cendrillon vient de s'installer
présentation de ce nouveau tableau avec
le marquis envie françois de breteuil
propriétaire des lieux
le mouvement de grève nationale
illimitée démarré le 6 février par les
salariés de carrefour market se poursuit
et touchent notamment le magasin de
voisins-le-bretonneux motif du
mécontentement les salaires la direction
propose des hausses de 0,6 à 0,7 pour
cent selon la cgt qui est à l'origine du
mouvement et ses représentants qui
manifestent ponctuellement devant
l'enseigne afin d'interpeller les
clients évoquent aussi les bénéfices en
hausse de plus de 10% de la direction
les clients qui sont aujourd'hui vingt
mille à avoir signé à travers la france
une pétition de soutien
on voit actuellement une direction pare
au niveau du carrefour groupe carrefour
actuellement à les augmentations de 11
9% soit à peu près un milliard 0 40 de
bénéfices et
on voit bien que là il ya deux choses
qui ne collent pas on voit qu'une chose
pour l'instant cet actionnariat
il est en train de se remplir les poches
et les salariés sont en train de voir
leurs salaires tout à fait diminuer à
savoir que chez nous quand même pas ce
côté là on a un côté de surendettement
de plus en plus on voit des gens qui
demandent des acomptes de plus en plus
de bonheur donc on en rit aujourd'hui
dans des conditions de travail qui sont
comme un catastrophique
et ça c'est partant en considération ces
valeureux devant la chose voilà donc
maintenant pour ce sujet concernant le
centre nautique de maurepas fermer une
mesure prise en urgence par le maire de
la commune et qui va impacter plus de
270 mille utilisateurs centre scolaire
associatif ou encore particuliers la
raison de cette décision
une sécurité qui ne peut plus être
assurée avec des millions d'euros de
travaux à réaliser
les précisions mélanie poker et william
l les portes sont closes depuis vendredi
dernier pour des raisons de sécurité
grégory gary astier maire de maurepas a
pris un arrêté municipal a pris la prise
de connaissance il ya quelques mois d'un
audit réalisé en 2009 en les dangers se
situe notamment aux faux plafonds et
également sur la charpente elle même
alors le faux plafond
les fixations sont totalement
endommagées et corrodé donc il ya un
risque de chute sur le public et sur la
structure elle même en est au delà de la
corrosion maximum il y avait déjà eu la
chute d'un élément du faux plafond
bien avant en 2006 ou 2007 je crois bien
à la suite de sa fille l'a été installés
pour protéger le public
mais une plaque du faux plafond est
également cette fois qui tombait il y un
peu plus d'un an
selon un audit complémentaire demandée
par la municipalité actuelle les travaux
s'évaluerait à 2 millions d'euros pour
la charpente seulement le centre
nautique accueille plus de 170 mille
utilisateurs par an dont 40 mille
scolaires qui viennent de maurepas et
l'encours et coignières datant de plus
de 40 ans la structure n'a jamais été
rénové
là on est dans une usure d'urgence tous
les scénarios sont envisageables
fermeture définitive destruction
reconstruction réaménagement de celle ci
pour le moment on n'en est pas là mais
en tout cas ma volonté de mer c'est
d'avoir un centre nautique sur la vie de
maurepas
en attendant qu'une décision soit prise
la commune va étudier diverses solutions
pour organiser une répartition des
usagers sur les piscines alentours la
fermeture d'urgence durera jusqu'au 3
mai prochain et le maire de maurepas à
grégory galeristes et qui sera l'invité
du journal demain mercredi pour revenir
sur cette décision en attendant que
pensez vous de cette fermeture vos
réponses est au micro de william l cissé
sécurité ça paraît utile oui dans quels
cas la fermeture me paraît en effet
justifié bas-côté ces questions de
sécurité je crois que la paix soit sur
moi j'habite le mesnil on nous avait
fait le coup
alors on dirait ça me concerne pas mais
fermé les pour réparation les centres
nautiques pendant la période d'été c'est
comme notre pas très judicieux en
question logique cette visite je la
connais depuis 30 ans et elle n'a jamais
changé toujours pareil donc et puis a
passé deux choses pour les enfants donc
moi ça ne me dérange pas du tout parce
que tu as mangé à l'est plus j'habite
meurent pas mais j'ai trouvé mieux
ailleurs donc c'est dommage
c'est très dommage mais si ça avait été
fait avant les travaux et aurait pas eu
tous y ait à faire maintenant
informations pratiques l'autoroute a13
sera fermé ce soir dès 22h et jusqu'à 5h
du matin dans le sens paris province à
la partir de poissy la direction des
routes d'ile-de-france procédant à la
dépose d'un portique de sécurité
endommagés suite à un récent accident il
vous faudra donc prendre la déviation à
partir de la sortie numéro 7 et
déviations empruntant la d 153 la d113
soyez attentifs à la signalisation pour
éviter les mauvaises surprises
benoît noble bonsoir vous êtes
conseiller municipal elle encourt
délégué à la question de la sécurité
civile de la prévention et des risques
des risques et du handicap
également en plateau ce soir à
l'occasion de la semaine du handicap qui
lie à des buts 12e édition jusqu'au 11
avril
le but d'une telle opération pour la
municipalité c'est changer le regard des
gens sur le handicap absolument puisque
le aujourd'hui quand on parle de
handicap
on parle surtout de problèmes
d'accessibilité vous connaissez la loi
de 2005 est en train de manger jusqu'au
1er janvier 2015 et qui aujourd'hui a
rencontré de grosses difficultés
donc on parle de handicap on parle
d'accessibilité et d'accès aux services
publics
mais on pense pas au reste on reste
c'est le regard sur la personne qui
portent un handicap
et la commune il encourra une très bonne
idée il ya une douzaine d'années tous
que c'est aujourd'hui d'ailleurs la fin
cette semaine la douzième édition qui
consiste non pas à porter le regard
factuelles sur un handicap mais regarde
plus élargie élargir le champ des
possibles que l'on dit très souvent ce
moment et échanger avec les personnes
qui sont porteuses d'un handicap pas
forcément les handicaps visible mais les
handicaps aussi invisible on va parler
de la programmation dans un instant mais
juste un mot peut-être tout de même sur
le factuel vous l'avez vous évoqué cette
loi de sur l'accessibilité qui oblige
les bâtiments publics à être aux normes
ça a été prolongée un délai
supplémentaire qui a été accordé juste
sur la ville d'elancourt vous en ai
toute cette mise aux normes autour du
handicap
alors nous nous avançons nous nous avons
une chronologie dans nos actions vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir que les baisses
de dotations de l'état nous ont
pénalisés mais on arrive à faire des
balances financière mais ça je laisserai
le soin à notre adjoint aux finances de
trouver les solutions avec monsieur
fourgous notre mère
on avance vous savez que cette loi
concié consistent surtout pour les
établissements de leurs recevant du
public les honneurs bim donc de
catégorie a à cinq qui en fonction du
nombre de populations de public 2
reçoivent se doivent
deux rues de se régulariser mais ce
serait une très longue et très technique
de vous exposer ce dossier ont préféré
ne s'est pas mis de côté ses anneaux
grêle au contraire nous avançons nous
nous développons nous favorisons
d'accessibilité et on est même largement
devant le grand nombre de nos petits
camarades
vous l'avez dit c'est très large il n'y
a pas que savoir accueillir le public
avec des locaux adaptés ya le regard
qu'il faut changer et le public aussi
rentrer en contact avec les agents de la
ville est ce que ces agents sont formés
ça fait partie de la politique de la
ville tout à fait donc la formation la
sensibilisation ne nous avons deux élus
martine de tout blonde et et michel
nounou riez qui sont très actives avec
le centre d'action sociale qui développe
cette accessibilité handicap
accessibilité je parle de ça pour tout
le monde comme net et découvrir le
handicap le personnel communal
en fait elle en a le profit mais
également les enfants des écoles
maternelles des centres aérés et puis
plus largement au grand public pour
qu'on ait cette vision un peu macro du
problème du handicap
il existe un service dédié au handicap
sur la veine elle encore intégré au sein
de l'action sociale mais composé par la
mutualisation des compétences et des
volontés de l'ensemble des services et
ça consiste en quoi ce service on y
trouvera des renseignements pratiques un
accueil spécifique spécialisés alors sur
ce type de problème selon vous avez la
partie administrative et la partie
technique donc la partie technique
on en a parlé ce sont ces
l'accessibilité et tous les problèmes de
déplacements liés aux déplacements ce
cas bus d'ailleurs travaille énormément
sur sur ce projet j'ai eu l'occasion de
rencontrer il ya peu de temps et si on
l'appelle l'aspect administratif et
l'aspect humain c'est-à-dire aider les
personnes qui ont besoin et on n'a pas
encore été assez loin dans ce domaine
mais bon on va pas jeter la pierre
aider ces personnes les accompagner pour
pouvoir
résoudre des problèmes du quotidien tant
financier qu'administratif qu'ils
rencontrent les changes c'est le mot
d'ordre de cette semaine sur elancourt
qui vient de s'ouvrir et qui va débuter
jusqu'au 11 avril cet échange justement
c'est difficile de créer du lien ou tout
simplement de changer un petit peu le
regard sur les personnes en situation de
handicap comment on peut faire changer
tout ça alors tout à l'heure on échange
et également sur les risques les gens
ont les gens la population règle
générale ne se sent concernés par le
handicap que quand elles ont une
personne qui est touché par ce même
handicap et d'où ce que notre échange de
tout à l'heure sur le handicap invisible
qui touche énormément de personnes en
france le handicap c'est 15% de la
population
c'est énorme on a des centaines de
milliers de personnes en fauteuil donc
qui ont ces problèmes d'accessibilité
mais à l'autre regard qui consiste à
mettre en avant l'aspect humain
connaître l'autre et c'est avoir une
vision complètement différente des
handicaps qui peuvent se gérer au
quotidien et ça ça passe aussi cet
échange changement de regard par le
sport il ya beaucoup de partenaires du
monde associatif sportif qui sur sept
sur sept semaines les associations de
montigny-le-bretonneux encore des longs
cours qui font du hand fauteuil par
exemple fait partie des animations de la
semaine
oui nous avons l'association est lancé
discover enfin d'autres associations que
je ne cite pas qu'ils sont très actives
dans ce domaine
vous parliez de handball vous aurez de
m'asseoir d'ailleurs j'y serai présent à
20h30 une démonstration de match de hand
ball en fauteuil et la possibilité pour
le public d'essayer le fauteuil pour
voir un petit peu dans quelles
conditions le regard n'est pas le même
et l'évolution n'est pas la même donc
c'est pédagogique
c'est ludique et et on va s'amuser
donc pendant que nous parlons sont
quelques images de montigny le
bretonneux qui organise aussi
régulièrement ça sonne bien de handicap
et qui sont diffusées quant aux images
concernant le hand fauteuil et de demain
sur hell encore vous les verrez sur
téléphiles dans une prochaine édition du
journal tout au long de l'année la ville
soutient les différentes associations
justement qui aident à la
sensibilisation au handicap qu'elle est
un peu la politique de la ville dans ce
domaine alors la politique donc avec les
personnes que j'ai cités tout à l'heure
c'est effectivement de maintenir un lien
tout au long de l'année et pas seulement
sur la semaine du handicap ce serait
trop facile
donc ce lien social permanent avec les
personnes
à mobilité réduite parce qu'on parle
aussi des personnes âgées non seniors
qui parfois ont des problèmes de molly
de mobilité qui ne sont pas des
personnes porteuses d'un handicap au
sens du dictionnaire mais avec des
problèmes d'arthrite donc de déplacement
de pénibilité est là notre service
social avec des gens adorables et très
très pertinent dans ce domaine et va
toujours à la rencontre chaque jour les
accompagnent dans des déplacements
restent à leur disposition pour pouvoir
échanger avec eux traiter leurs
problèmes au quotidien ou quelle que
soit la nature du problème et ça c'est
franchement sur l'encours il c'est plus
un effort c'est une continuité depuis
douze ans et ça ne ça ne va qu'en
s'améliorant
vous parliez tout à l'heure de cette de
ce problème on va dire ça comme ça des
gens qui ne réalise finalement le
handicap que lorsqu'ils y sont
confrontés par un proche ou par eux
mêmes
il ya toute une sensibilisation à faire
autour de ça une prévention des risques
aussi ça s'inscrit dans cette dynamique
là vous qui venez du domaine associatif
un oui oui je connais bien le milieu
associatif et effectivement les gens
parfois on peur le handicap fait peur
que va-t-on dire comment va-t-on
s'adresser à la personne est ce qu'on ne
va pas la froisser est-ce qu'on va pas
lui rappeler un malheureux événements je
dis aux gens et les personnes de nos
associations spécialisées et et nos élus
et notre personnel municipal qui est
spécialisée sur ce domaine veut
justement créé ce lien pour dire
échangeons parlons des problèmes et si
chacun donne un peu c'est tout le monde
qui recevra beaucoup donc c'est ça
l'important
pour revenir sur les différentes
animations qui seront proposées jusqu'au
11 avril on évoquait le sport demain
soir à notamment cette animation de hand
fauteuil il ya d'autres temps forts sur
cette semaine qu'on pouvait tout à fait
vous aurez des échanges des débats un
médecin dont j'ai perdu le nom qui sera
présent par là pour parler de noro des
problèmes neurologiques puisque
l'handicap que je vous le disais ce
n'est pas que le physique c'est
peut-être aussi cognitive sensitif etc
et vous aurez également des projections
cinématographiques sur notre cinéma
vous aurez également un don du sang un
dépistage de diabète le diabète est un
gros problème de société aujourd'hui un
loto loto qui sera adapté avec la langue
des signes qu'on appelle basiquement le
lsf pour permettre à toutes les
personnes malvoyantes ou aveugles de
pouvoir y participer et à toutes les
autres personnes qui ne présentent pas
de handicaps particuliers qui vont
pouvoir se rendre compte
ça c'est important de faire des moments
d'échangés où tout le monde se retrouve
qui handicape ou pas on dit qu'un des
chauffeurs des activités en commun en
fait les changes c'est le socle si y'a
pas des changes
il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de vie de
société donc c'est monsieur fourgous et
son équipe l'ont bien compris depuis des
années c'est pour ça qu'ils ont lancées
sur ce thème
et c'est une innovation qu'on va
continuer à développer la base de tout
c'est les changes il faut échanger avec
les personnes qui portent un handicap
il s'est pas honteux ou de ne pas en
avoir un ou d'en avoir un il faut
échanger juste pour conclure vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure on n'attend pas la
semaine du handicap pour se mobiliser
cette fois que la semaine sera terminé
il y aura d'autres rendez vous d'autres
actions qui vont être menées aujourd'hui
les efforts portent sur quoi alors lisez
les efforts portent sur ce son vient de
l'évoquer la sensibilisation les change
donc tout au long de l'année nous créons
des réunions des échanges des voyages
des déplacements on fait attention c'est
comme vous savez nous nos budgets sont
plutôt revues à la baisse
mais on ne lâche pas la faire et pour
nous c'est un point essentiel que de
pouvoir que toutes les tranches de la
population
puissent échanger entre elles malgré les
économies qu'il faut faire le budget
dédié au handicap à la santé on n'y
touche pas non on essaye de patrons et
touché en tout cas non non non surtout
pas il y a des fondamentaux je vous
parlais de socle tout à l'heure vous
avez des piliers y compris pour la
france en france le l'un des piliers
c'est le bénévolat vous n'allez plus de
bénévoles j'aurais tendance à dire on a
pu vous n'avez pas de république donc
bail en cours c'est pareil nous avons
des gens qui sont mobilisés qui sont
qu'il faut qu'ils ont des activités
extra professionnelles même pour les
personnels communaux et qui
s'investissent dès qu'ils le peuvent
pour pouvoir accompagner les personnes
qui le souhaitent et qui ont besoin
justement de sortir un peu de leur de
leur quotidien
merci la semaine du handicap sur la
ville d'elancourt c'est jusqu'au 11
avril et le programme complet et bien
sûr sur le site de la ville d'elancourt
merci encore nous poursuivons ce journal
est beau temps oblige les chasses aux
oeufs organisée pour ce long week end de
pâques ont rencontré un grand succès
auprès des familles nous étions à saint
cyr l'école et à voisins le bretonneux
dans l'herbe derrière les arbres ou
l'effeuillage
dimanche il fallait être efficace face à
la concurrence pour récolter les oeufs
laissés par les cloches dont le parc de
la croix bleue à voisins le bretonneux
il faut chercher il faut se dépêcher
il faut à la concentration parce qu'il
faut qu'on verrait aussi faut attraper
les iv dont les buissons
une chasse traditionnelle pour les
chasseurs de chocolat ravit tout comme
leurs chefs des tribus se redonne
l'occasion de retrouver d'autres
camarades de courir un peu partout
recherché et ils sont très contents
ensuite d'avoir trouvé leurs voeux donc
c'est un bon moment à passer en famille
pour ceux qui se sentaient plus l'âme
d'un gladiateur que d'un chasseur
saint-cyr-l'ecole redonner vie à
l'histoire pour ce week-end pascal de
rome à gergovie
les enfants ont pu rencontrer de vrais
romain ou encore construire un char pour
participer à une course à décorer
macherano de façon à pons on a fait la
course mon attaque année c'était bien un
truc en famille l'annoncé a fait le
parcours en moi et ça a l'air
intéressant pour leur âge
donc je suis venu avec une amie et c'est
plutôt conviviale et puis sympathique
heureusement il peut pas trop donc on a
de la chance
saint-cyr antique c'est la thématique
événementiel de l'année 2015 pour la
ville et ce qu'elle admire énigmes et
jeux d'adressé les gaulois et les
romains étaient partout votre compère
d'armes entre les chiens kenya mais pas
suffisamment pour voler la vedette au
chocolat voilà donc pour ce sujet
consacré à la chasse aux oeufs et cette
chasse aux oeufs a aussi été proposé aux
enfants qui se sont rendus au château de
breteuil traditionnel rendez vous et ils
ont le droit aussi à ses enfants et à
leur famille un petit bonus
l'établissement dévoilé un son et
lumière dédié à cendrillon trois mois de
travail nécessaires pour la réalisation
de ce tableau animé c'est le quatrième
après la belle au bois dormant le petit
chaperon rouge encore le chat botté
william bell
cendrillon rochas ses souliers au
château de breteuil le célèbre conte de
perrault est mise en scène dans un
spectacle son et lumière de 4 minutes et
c'est juste le temps qu'il faut pour
retomber en enfance
si j'ai choisi cendrillon c'est parce
qu'elle se double aspect de comme je le
disais deux à la fois de la pauvreté et
de la et de la réussite en quelque sorte
par ses belles princesses et puis je
dirais que la seconde raison c'est la
sortie du film de walt disney qui est
magnifique que j'ai vu après le dessin
animé est bien connu l'ag se trouvait
que c'était bien pour breteuil de sortir
au même moment que le film
ce spectacle comme un écho au film de
disney a tout de même nécessité trois
mois de travail
l'animation des nombreux personnages
étant essentiellement basés sur les jeux
de lumière c'était le jeu finalement
d'assez complexe il fallait fabriquer
les chevaux il fallait bien sûr
fabriquer deux personnages
la bande son fait en studio ensuite la
coordination entre la bande son et les
éclairages donc c'était un long et
patient travail ici l'histoire n'est pas
racontée en entier elle s'arrête à la
fin du bal lorsque cendrillon abandonne
sa pantoufle
l'occasion de relire la fin en entrant
chez soi c'est aussi beau je crois sais
pas ce qui m'a plu c'est surtout la
façon
enfin la rapidité la borne et met le
papier ensuite il met canarien let et on
ramène le papier invité est incroyable
c'est le quatrième contes de perrault
qui est mise à l'honneur au château de
breteuil l'écrivain ayant été proche de
louis de breteuil à l'époque contrôleur
des finances de louis xiv et pour
profiter du spectacle
rendez-vous tous les dimanches aux
écuries du château avant minuit
évidemment 10 sport à présent avec la
aiguilles en cours ce qui faisait son
retour ce week end après l'annulation de
l'édition 2014 pour cause d'élections
municipales quatre courses étaient au
programme 3 course e jeunes à partir de
8 ans la course principale de 10 km
ouverte à partir de 16 ans le à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines toujours en
charge de l'organisation
michael nidau et elodie moines pour les
images d'une grande boucle dans la
nature un parcours vallonné de longues
lignes droites sur la route bienvenue
sur la nuit en course ce dimanche pour
cette 21e édition 300 ce courage ont
pris le départ des 10 km et sportifs ont
une nouvelle fois souffert pour
atteindre la ligne d'arrivée
il ya quelques difficultés notamment au
7e km à peu près il ya une petite côte à
monter qui sera précédé de quelques
escaliers aussi donc je pense que les
coureurs à ce niveau là quand
commenceront à avoir mal aux jambes
c'était une course difficile cette fois
ci parce qu'ils ont eu la très bonne
idée de nous mettre des escaliers au
milieu du parcours
juste avant une petite côte donc c'était
le double effet kiss cool avec un grand
soleil printanier des température plutôt
douce le temps était idéal ce dimanche
pour réaliser des performances
rascal bredele à saint quentin en
yvelines a terminé sur la plus haute
marche du podium
il a fini la course en 34 minutes 0-2 le
coureur devant son dauphin françois
l'acquis de près d'une minute
les conditions climatiques elle était
vraiment excellente
il le soleil était l'accès à ses frais
ce qui permettait de bien respirer
durant sa course donc voila c'était
franchement un très très grand plaisir
d'autant plus qu'on a eu beaucoup de
participants étaient 350 le week-end de
pâques m'ont franchement c'est un réel
plaisir pour les coureurs mais aussi
pour les organisateurs vous rendez vous
l'année prochaine pour une 22e édition
de la glu en course les coureurs sont
déjà impatients
vivement l'année prochaine voire
vivement la prochaine grille en course
elle les championnats départementaux de
pony games était organisé ce week end au
centre équestre de l'île de loisirs à
saint quentin en yvelines une vingtaine
d'équipés yvelinoise composé est de cinq
cavaliers qui participent à la
compétition la cavalière 1 marion
jeanniot du club hippique ville vers de
jouy en josas nous présente cette
discipline elle était au micro et
d'élodie mois le pony games et surtout
des jeux de rapidité d'agilité de
patience parfois des équipes parce que
l'esprit d'équipé très important et
voilà il ya des jeux avec des bals des
conapo enfin débat la poser sur l'icône
des cartons à mettre dans des seaux
enfin c'est très divers ça bouge ça
envoie on n'est pas fan change de
dusseau dresse basique à l'esprit
d'équipé que je pousse génial et voilà
et du côté des résultats c'est le club
hippique ville vers 2h wicked
l'ajustement emporté pour connaître
l'ensemble des résultats sportifs du
week-end sur notre secteur rendez vous
dans quelques minutes avec michael et
demi d'euros et le 7-8 sport
exceptionnellement 1 mardi
elle en dit nous avons donc célébrer
pâques le journal en tout cas revient
demain aux mêmes horaires le replay sur
notre site internet excellente soirée